Drake's latest album, "Scorpion,"
debuted at number one
on the Billboard charts
and had one of the biggest
weeks ever for a hip-hop album.
But to listen to the entire project,
you're going to have to
dedicate a lot of time.
It's Drake's longest album.
It's 25 tracks and has a running time
of one hour and 30 minutes.
But Drake isn't the only
artist with a bloated album.
The deluxe edition of Chris Brown's latest
was a 57-track behemoth
that ran for a solid
three hours and 18 minutes.
That's longer than "The Two Towers."
Migos followed a similar
path with "Culture II,"
which had nearly twice
the amount of tracks
as their previous album, "Culture."
But these lengthier albums
aren't just a coincidence.
It might just be a response
to the way we consume music.
To understand, you're
going to have to look
at streaming services.
Spotify and Apple Music have completely
changed the music industry.
In 2017, 54% of music consumption
came from streaming platforms,
and streaming generated $3.9 billion.
But the Billboard charts
have had a hard time
trying to figure out how to count streams
in an industry that was once dominated
by physical album sales.
In 2014, people sat around,
debated, deliberated,
and ultimately decided on a way
to quantify streaming music:
1,500 streamed songs
counted as one album sale.
Previously, Billboard didn't
take streaming into account.
It only counted the sales of full albums.
This caused a huge shakeup
in the music industry.
Record labels and artists quickly realized
that more tracks equals more streams,
and that ultimately equals more money.
Artists like Eminem,
Post Malone, and Future
all held top stops on the
hip-hop charts in 2017,
with albums that averaged
at least 18 tracks.
Suddenly an individual
track could help an artist
reach number one on the Billboard charts
without selling any physical albums,
which was hugely beneficial for hip-hop,
because streaming made up 89%
of hip-hop consumption in 2017.
That's one of the reasons Drake
might have added "Hotline
Bling" onto "Views."
By adding that one track,
Drake almost guaranteed his
album would go platinum.
It had 400 million
streams that converted to
267,000 streaming albums before
"Views" was even released.
So if an artist has a
massive hit like "One Dance"
or "God's Plan," it can help
turn an album into a hit.
Streaming listeners quickly pluck
their favorite tracks from albums,
put them on playlists, and
then reject the leftovers.
In 2015, a research company found that 60%
of streaming service listeners
only listen to albums
a few times, because they're
discovering so much new music.
So the more tracks you have,
the higher chance you have
of making a song that lands on a playlist.
But it didn't always work this way.
Music was once dominated by
different physical formats.
Vinyl, cassettes, and
CDs all had restrictions
that dictated an album's length.
But no matter how long
or short an album was,
if one album was purchased
that meant one unit was sold.
But that same rule doesn't apply anymore.
Streaming is the dominant
format, which means
the 25 tracks on "Scorpion"
make a lot more sense.
You could argue that
Drake is a prolific artist
who enjoys making long albums,
or he's an incredible businessman
who understands his audience's habits.
But no matter how you
feel about streaming,
it's completely altered
the way we listen to music
and the way music is made,
for better or for worse.
Artists are still trying to experiment
and find their footing
on these new platforms.
Kanye West took the opposite
approach from Drake,
releasing a bunch of albums
that were only seven tracks long.
Some have argued that the shorter length
helps with the album's replay value,
although you'll need to
listen to Kanye's album
a lot more times to reach 1,500 streams.